aller plus loin sur ce discours avec
vous roselyne febvre que discours que
vous avez pu suivre en direct sur france
24 plusieurs points importants à retenir
déjà jean castex justifie les efforts
diplomatiques de la france emmanuel
macron a tout essayé avec vladimir
poutine oui il faut continuer c'est ce
qu'il a c'est ce qu'il a dit alors il ya
quatre principes qui là qu'il a énoncés
qui sont les principes on va dire les
quatre piliers de en tout cas de la de
las de cette crise pour l'épauler france
est un la fermeté on l'a vu sur les
sanctions économiques
de la donc la fermeté de la solidarité
c'est à dire en termes d'armement on l'a
vu aussi et en termes aussi de crises
humanitaires c'est à dire d'aidé à la
fois les les ukrainiens qui fuient leur
pays et les pays limitrophes qui vont
les recevoir et en l'occurrence la
france bien évidemment aussi et puis
l'unité il l'a dit au sens au sein de
l'otan et au sein de l'union européenne
donc si l'objectif de vladimir poutine
s'était de laisser croire que la franc
que l'otan était en mort cérébrale comme
l'avait dit emmanuel macron et bien il
ne reprend du service et l'union
européenne
pareil aimé boutines voulait veulent à
diviser et bien il l'a unifiée et puis
enfin le maintien du dialogue et c'est
répondre à votre question sur ben voilà
il ya toujours une place pour la
diplomatie faut continuer voilà vous
voyez ces images en direct là c'est un
débat avec s'est ouvert avec les
différents chefs de groupe sur cette
guerre en ukraine au juste après
l'allocution de jean castex
clarification aussi donné par jean
castex puisqu'il vient donner aussi la
position de l'exécutif français sur
cette sale guerre en ukraine il a des
mots durs contre le contrôle de la
douleur poutine il parle d'une agression
cynique et préméditée de vladimir
poutine oui les termes sont durs mais on
a on a entendu aussi ce matin bruno le
maire dire que nous allions provoqué
l'effondrement de l'économie de la
russie ce qui n'a pas tardé d'ailleurs à
avoir une réaction côté russe en dix ans
une menace fait attention
à ce que vous dites mais visiblement
jean castex n'a pas peur et continue de
dire que bien sûr tout le mal qu'il
pense de vladimir poutine alors la
campagne présidentielle n'est jamais
loin il faut aussi montrer que
l'exécutif même si on a quarante jours
du premier tour est toujours à l'oeuvre
les sanctions russe elles vont avoir des
impacts sur les français et donc
l'exécutif planche actuellement sur un
plan ce qu'il appelle jean castex un
plan de résilience pour atténuer l'effet
des sanctions sur les français oui comme
emmanuel macron l'avait dit également le
cette crise va avoir un effet forcément
domino sur toute l'europe et en
particulier la france et il va falloir
s'y préparer bien évidemment ce sera
difficile - peut-être que les ukrainiens
mais il y aura des répercussions
économiques
d'autant qu'on sort quand même d'une
crise pandémique et que vient se
rajouter cette crise ukrainienne mais je
voudrais juste souligné que l' on a vécu
quand même des moments assez rare à
l'assemblée nationale d'habitude c'est
un endroit où on s'écharpe par ses chars
poussé on appelle ça journaliste
politique le guignol l'assemblée
nationale même si ça ne mérite pas son
nom puisqu'il ya de vrai débat
démocratique mais souvent ça vole pas
très haut et là depuis longtemps on
n'avait pas vu tous les députés debout
et applaudir très fort ce l'ambassadeur
d'ukraine tout aussi comme au parlement
européen un jour historique bien sûr
vous et lynch qui a pris la parole et
devant le parlement européen donc ce
sont des moments politiques extrêmement
fort parce qu'il y à ce qu'il se passe
sur le terrain en ukraine et ce qui se
passe sur les scènes politiques
européennes moi cette image que vous
avez pu suivre en direct sur france 24
donc l'ambassadeur ukrainien en france
qui a été applaudi très très longuement
et vous avez pu le voir aussi dans
l'hémicycle les députés tous les députés
qui arbore donc un type insa les vigiles
l'ukraine et des masques
aussi à l'effigié du club on a
d'ailleurs vu le député de la france
insoumise adrien 4,9
acquiescé lors du discours de jean
castex alors que effectivement la france
a soumise à une position un peu ambigu
sur la russie et sur vladimir poutine
oui c'est vrai que non pas des
admirateurs mais encore en jean luc
mélenchon a toujours dit que l'agresseur
s'était c'était les états unis envers
envers la russie est aujourd'hui milian
évidemment il rétropédaler ça fait
parfois un peu non pas de peine mais
c'est un peu tragique c'est du un peu du
tragi comique de voir dans le fond les
uns et les autres et il n'y a pas que
jean luc mélenchon il ya aussi marine le
pen eric zemmour nicolas dupont aignan
qui ont été loin jusqu'à dire qu'il
rêvait d'un poutine pour eric zemmour en
france donc on les voit tous un peu
pédaler dans la semoule pour faire
rétropédaler et dans le fond ils sont en
quelque sorte décrédibilisé par eux
mêmes par leurs propres paroles parce
qu'aujourd'hui vladimir poutine devient
le monstre pour le coup l'agresseur et
il passe un peu tous pour pardonnez moi
l'expression mais rappelez-vous ce que
disait jean luc mélenchon avant que
françois hollande ne soit élu est ce que
la france veut d'un capitaine de pédalos
on peut se demander si là il n'y a pas
quatre capitaines de wah ya un
sujet très épineux c'est le sujet des
réfugiés jean castex l'évoquent en
disant que la france va havrais pour une
juste je sais juste répartition des
efforts d'accueil entre les pays de
l'union européenne la france n'annonce
pas qu'elle va accueillir directement
sur son sol des réfugiés parce que c'est
un sujet qui est qui est explosive
explosive dans cette campagne mais
vraiment on a bien compris que la france
ne disait pas
quelqu'un
elle n'a qu'à y aurait pas de craignent
un en tout cas c'est parce que j'ai
compris mais c'est elle reste elle reste
absolument vague parce que on est à 40
jours de l'élection présidentielle et
que c'est un sujet qui de fait partie de
ce qu'on va dire de cendres de panique
qui peut prendre les certains français
on l'a vu un de craindre de submersion
de voilà mais en l'occurrence la france
se doit d'accueillir les réfugiés elle
le sait et d'ailleurs cette aide qu'elle
soit logistique qu'elle soit envers les
réfugiés ou envers les pays qui les
accueille dans un premier temps qui est
d'ailleurs la pologne la france sera
bien évidemment dans l'obligation est
dans le devoir de le faire et elle le
fera mais vous avez raison elle ne le
dit pas de manière de manière claire et
nette on est le projet pense pas qu'il
ya un doute à avoir non mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un gars ce texte est resté
assez vague dans la sémantique on est le
1er mars dans trois jours c'est la date
limite pour déposer les candidatures
pour se présenter à cette élection
présidentielle
emmanuel macron revêt un petit peu là
les habits de chef de guerre même si la
guerre n'est pas n'est pas évidemment
sur notre territoire
c'est savent ça va le pousser dans les
sondages mais oui on le voit déjà quand
on regarde le dernier rolling hier soir
le rolling c'est l'ifop qui fait de
chaque soir à 17 heures un nouveau
sondage et on voit que emmanuel macron
prend deux points
d'autres sondages aussi marine le pen
est toujours en numéro 2 mais les autres
davis
notamment valérie pécresse eric zemmour
et jean luc mélenchon ils perdent ce
soit d un point où un demi point donc on
voit bien que emmanuel macron et à la
tête et le sait le capitaine à la tête
du bateau en pleine tempête
alors il ne va pas dire il ne dira
jamais que cette guerre il en a rêvé ou
qu'ils le souhaitaient bien évidemment
que non mais force est de constater
qu'elle le cerf elle le sert dans sa
posture de deux présidents et d'ailleurs
je pense que sont sa candidature il
devra l'annoncé jeu il est obligé de la
côte sajoo avant l'annoncé là le 4 mars
mais comme il l'a dit et c'était presque
prémonitoire je serai président jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure c'est ce qui
risque d'arriver et ce qui risque
d'arriver également c'est la façon dont
ça va être dit déclaré soit ça va être
lancée d'une manière anodine je suis
candidat pour vite passer à d'autres à
autre chose ou alors au contraire en
faire un moment solennel et en disant
dans le fond je suis le capitaine depuis
cinq ans à la tête de la france je suis
président de l'europe je connais les
dossiers je connais le sujet est en gros
faites moi confiance je sais comment il
faut faire pour sortir deux sets de 7 à
la fois impasse diplomatique et de cette
crise ukrainienne on a vu que le coc vu
qu'il avait fait un petit stage quand
même d'une autre nature mais avec cette
pandémie quand même qui montrait qu'il
avait pu en tout cas comme d'autres pays
d'ailleurs
avoir été avoir mené cette bataille en
tout cas sans trop de dégâts il faut
dire que le quoi qu'il en coûte avait
aidé et que la france avait était là
auprès des entreprises et des gens pour
qu'ils ne fassent pas faillite ce qui
n'a pas eu lieu dans d'autres pays parce
qu'on est un certain reprocher parfois
un état nounou en touche un état
protecteur vous rappeler que quand
emmanuel macron a été élu il a dit je
serai à la fois le réformateur et le
protecteur en quelque sorte il n'a pas
vraiment pu être le réformateur
mais il s'est attelé à tenter d'être en
tout cas le protecteur merci beaucoup